Enrique Acevedo is a Univision anchor
and he joins the story que thank you for
coming on so ice in addition to the many
things that it does of course it it
arrests and Deportes thousands and
thousands of criminal aliens illegal
aliens in the United States who've been
convicted of felonies and it supports
some that is its job no other agency
does that if we abolish ice who will do
that there's a lot of confusion about
what ice is and the confusion in part
has to do with the fact that many people
believe that their job is as you were
describing in your introduction to try
to stop immigrants one they want to come
through the border that's the Border
Patrol's job that's not ice ice mission
has to do with human trafficking it has
to do with you know trying to prosecute
the companies that are hiring and
exploiting undocumented immigrants in
the United States and part of the
problem is that it has stayed away from
that mission and is not only focused on
mass deportation but again ice and you
may not agree with everything that ice
does but if we abolish ice who will
arrest the thousands and thousands of
convicted felons who are in our country
illegally who will interdict the
fentanyl that's flowing across our
borders from Mexico who will fulfill
those roles who will protect the country
no one seems to be answering that well
first of all the vast majority I would
say 80 percent of those arrested by ice
are people who have no criminal records
they're not rapists or murderers they're
not criminals they're just undocumented
immigrants they're only understand I
understand we can debate whether you
know that should be a crime that we
prosecute for but we do know that there
are as Donald Trump said and roundly
mocked for saying it there are actually
rapists who come in
I'm not saying to millions of them but
there are some there are thousands of
convicted felons in this country legally
without ice do we just let them stay I
mean what is the answer since
just going to the abolition of ice know
there are thousands of them and I'm
sorry about the wind we're in a
high-rise here in Mexico City but I
don't know there are thousands of them
say there are some cases and then we
have police officers we have law
enforcement that can take I don't think
highs has to be worried about that like
I would say it has to be worried about
human trafficking organizations about
companies that are improving and
exploiting undocumented workers that are
attracting a lot of undocumented
immigrants into the u.s. and not
focusing solely on separating families
in other words in other words you know
hero you know care really what happens
to those criminals within our borders I
mean that's the the answer let me ask
you a more basic question should someone
who overstayed his visa in the United
States be deported you see we can use
our resources much better much much
better okay
so if you overstay your visa you get a
tourist fees that come the United States
and this happens you know hundreds of
thousands of times annually and you
ignore the length of your visa you're
here illegally should you be deported
well of course I think if you are in the
country without documents right now you
should have to follow the right process
and the process right now goes for
deportation this is the thing there are
millions of people in that situation who
do we report first how do we start
do we deport families that have been
here for 15 20 years obeying the laws or
so let's start by people who have
committed a crime without ice we're not
gonna be deporting people committing
crimes
so I'm asking on the other end to even
deport people who proceed their visas if
illegal immigration makes a country so
much better have to make a choice in the
third quarter port first okay we we
actually don't have very know what we
can afford this but I want to ask you
though if importing a lot of poor people
from Central America makes your country
better why hasn't it made Tijuana better
to have thousands of Central Americans
there was the last time you went to
Tijuana soccer because I'm happy to go
with you we can go next week they have
incredible
once the cities you know much much
better than it was a couple of decades
ago it's a boner I grew up in they're
alive
incredible astonishment so let's show
the 2.0 so you can see it's not the
horrible place you just described look
what would I'm not saying it's a
horrible place what I'm saying is that
there are hundreds of thousands of
people in Tijuana in legal limbo Mexico
doesn't want to let them stay and my
question is why not if having
undocumented immigrants is you describe
them in your country makes your country
better then why does in Mexico give them
all Mexican citizenship tomorrow and let
them vote in the upcoming presidential
election real question well a couple of
things first of all since Donald Trump
became president Mexico has deported
over 200,000 immigrants to Central
America 200,000 that's 200,000
immigrants that could be at the US
border today so Mexico is doing
something to stop undocumented
immigration from flowing to the u.s.
those who decide not to stay in Mexico
don't say not because the Mexican
government is asking them to leave
they're decided to go to the US they
don't want to stay in Mexico because
they're fleeing violence and like we
discussed before Mexico is not exactly a
safe heaven when you wanna flee violence
whatever wait a second there were
eighteen hundred murders in Tijuana last
year 1800 murders if again having
hundreds of thousands of illegal
immigrants from Central America in your
city makes it better than why did you
have 1800 murders last year
I mean murder rate than Tijuana no
actually you can't that's not true you
cannot name ten cities in America I'd
name them right thousand people die each
year because I've gone related violence
in this country that's a fact isn't it
the majority the majority this also by
just I mean Cape and they're all so many
cities that have violent crime like with
Chicago like Detroit okay for Mexico
there's there's there's no reason to to
be a
our agent for the country of Mexico here
you don't need to defend Mexico I'm just
asking you a question someone who
understands Mexico you know as well as I
that when you have an influx of poor
people with low education levels and no
jobs it does not make you richer it
makes you poorer so why are you
pretending that the United States
benefits from taking in millions of poor
people with low education levels I can
think of many examples of immigrant
families that came to the US with
nothing and then became dynasties the
Kennedys for example from Ireland which
i think is also the country of your
family's background so no that's just
one example the Rockefellers many of
them came to the US without a penny in
their pocket and they became dynasty
exactly so okay so when you come when
they come into the country what I'm
saying is there there are very
impressive immigrants I would never deny
that I know a lot of them they're great
people and I'm glad they're here but
when you import millions of poor people
into your country your country is over
let's stop lying about it yeah okay now
there's a reality-based show no it's
good for the economy aggression is good
for the economy Tucker and it's you know
why it's been great for Tijuana yeah
yeah that's why you're kicking about
great great to see you thanks very much